hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from today's title Tuesday I
was suggested to me by Matthew Hoffman
on Twitter so thank you for that uh it's
hikarnakamura versus Armenian
International master I mean
and it's a really wild game features a
position that we have not seen before
it's a really awesome uh let's check it
out so hikar with the white pieces opens
with Pawn to E4 that's that's a king
obviously Ponte E5 Knight the C3 he goes
for the Vienna game Knight to F6 and now
not F4 but Bishop to C4 inviting black
to go for Knight captures on e4 and
that's exactly what Emin goes for he
goes for Knight captures on e4 but
Hikaru doesn't take if you take uh then
D5 and black is perfectly fine might be
even better so here Hikaru goes Queen to
H5 he threatens Checkmate and now we
have Knight back to D6 defending on F7
and also inviting Queen captures on E5
and even though Queen captures an E5 is
perfectly fine then black just um okay
black and blue Bishop D7 but also you
can just play Queen D7 and uh add trade
queens and nothing really is happening
here so Hikaru goes back with the bishop
Bishop to B3 Bishop to E7 and now Knight
to F3 Hikaru will uh recapture an E5 but
when he uh finishes development we have
Knight to C6 and only now Knight
captures on E5 we have Pawn to G6 now
you have to be careful if you put the
queen to a weird Square then you're
gonna blunder the Knight on E5 so Queen
back to E2 uh here aiming castles uh and
Hikaru also castles and here we have
Rook to E8 and it is now as of move 9
that we have a completely new game so
what can Hikaru do here he goes Knight
to D5 and it's very interesting you keep
your queen on the same file as The Rook
here but it doesn't appear that there's
much black can do about this however
Amin does try he plays Bishop to F6 with
a move like Bishop to H4 or Ponte 5
black is still uh very much in the game
but after much to F6 uh Hikaru finds a
nice breakthrough and that is Knight
captures on F7 where really if black
wants to keep the position equal he does
have the captain
on F7 and it feels very unpleasant
because you you know you're going under
the mask of the bishop but King captures
would have been the way to go and now
the problem is uh White has to settle
for Knight captures on C7 if you play
Knight captures and F6 yes the king is
on F6 but there's just no good follow-up
you you don't have any pieces in the
game and you don't have time to to
develop them so what you would have to
settle for is Knight captures on C7
opening up a discovery here and once the
king moves okay you capture an E8 Queen
captures let's say queen captures Knight
captures and you get this position where
D4 is coming white is up to pawns but
black has two knights for a rook so uh a
nice trade-off but basically an equal
equal possession so instead after Knight
captures on F7 Rook captures on YouTube
was played going for the immediate Queen
trade but this now does favor Hikaru
Knight captures and d8 with Bishop
capture 78 and now Knight characters and
C7 with check opening up a discovery
from her good friend the busher with
King to evade Knight captures on E8 and
now the problem is how does Hikaru get
the Knight back into the game if black
is allowed to play B6 Bishop B7 and
Bishop captures black will just be up
too much material so what did Hikaru
have in mind here I mean goes for Pawn
to B6 we have Pawn to D3 by Hikaru and
now Bishop to B7 going after the Knight
and it seems like black will uh capture
the Knight and uh get back into the game
however there is a line that just
destroys black so feel free to pause the
video and to win this position for
Hikaru while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
Knight can indeed be saved and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is best of the H6 with check and now
look at the mighty Bishop pair forcing
the king to go to the to the E file it
doesn't matter if you go King to E7 or
King the E8 in the game King the E8 was
played and now Rook F to E1 forcing a
captioning one because uh if you don't
capture you're just gonna lose the Rook
on E2 so Rook captures other Rook
captures also with check and now what do
you play this is the problem the King
has no squares the Bishops are
incredible here just covering all the
squares uh The Rook covers the E file uh
basically the only thing you can do is
move the Knight to the E7 you could also
Play Bishop to E7 but then you no longer
have control over the C7 square and then
the Knight can uh go back into the game
so Knight the E7 was played but now
Bishop to F4 attacking the Knight and
now again if you trade then Hikaru is
just up too much material and and
there's no way to defend the night this
is covered by the Knight so you can play
Bishop to C7 the Knight cannot move
because of the Rook otherwise okay you
could maybe defend the Knight with the
Knight but this way you have no squares
so Knight the C8 was played but uh it is
not enough Knight the C7 with check now
you have to capture if you play King the
f8 then Bishop to H6 is mate in one as
the E8 was really your only Square uh
where you could move your king So Bishop
captures on C7 the Knight survives this
uh we have Bishop captures and now Pawn
to D6 but just Bishop to E6 not allowing
the the bishop to be chased with a move
like King to D7 so just Bishop to E6
King to f8 and here he carplayed Bishop
to d8 and he was in this position on
move 23 that Emin Ohanian resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here and it's uh okay it's not really
it's one but you are down material
Hikaru has um
a rook for a night uh there's really
nothing nothing good that you can do
here if you try something like King T8
then just Bishop captures on C8 and now
everything is hanging both the bishop
and B7 and the Knight on E7 if captures
then captures on B7 one way you could
maybe continue after Bishop to d8 is
something like Bishop to C6 okay you
maybe don't uh suffer severe material
loss immediately but that there's really
nothing for you to do you're you're down
two pawns and you're down the exchange
uh it would be uh silly to continue this
and of course here I mean oh honey I
just resigned the game so very nicely
done by Hikaru going for this uh very
very tricky line of the Vienna uh with
Bishop to C4 very nicely done I hope you
enjoyed it then maybe you can also try
it in your own games if you if you are
also a AV and a player uh so yeah that's
the game hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank uh Modi Stefano Steinbach
Alejandro Maldonado uh Carlos Roddy and
the David Kimura for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
I thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day